that was such a weird choice i made on
the day
it wasn't scripted it was improvised
i was i was there i saw the crowd i
heard the beats i thought like zemo
needs to
show his moves
daniel i'm loving the mustache thank you
this is not
a personal hipster choice but um
i started filming in prague it's a movie
set in the first world war
so that's what i got even if it was a
personal hipsters choice i really like
it
okay so we haven't seen zemo in quite a
bit
did you think you would be back coming
back to the mcu or did you think
uh zemo's story was over it's always a
good sign when they don't kill you
um so um i was always hoping for
um um a potential return but i
i didn't know anything i didn't know
about any plan they had in mind for zemo
so it really um took me by surprise when
i got the call
and i was in um hungary shooting another
show
that i revisited and then i i talked to
the director and
um i think a week later she um she came
to budapest
with a very funky looking suitcase um
where uh my mask uh was uh you know
presented to me in a very ceremonial
kind of way um and and then i was
i was totally uh enthusiastic uh
about uh about this show because um
i thought not only can i revisit a
character that i really liked
but also i can do something else with it
i can wear the iconic mask
i can show his aristocratic background
there's much more sense of humor in it
for me
um so i didn't have the impression that
i
would repeat myself that's interesting
they came with like a like a briefcase
full of money but it was
like what do you think and it was so uh
she said
uh she couldn't she had to have it on
her so it was hand luggage
and obviously some security guys in
hungary
said well can we have a look and so
imagine a woman
traveling with that purple mask so much
that's what this is zemo made quite the
re-entrance especially um with your
little dance move moment have you seen
the reactions from everyone
it is so crazy because that was such a
weird choice i made on the day it wasn't
scripted it was improvised
i was i was there i saw the crowd i
heard the beats i thought like zemo
needs to
show his moves he needs to let off some
steam after sitting in a
in a in a dodgy german prison for years
so
and especially every possibility to
annoy sam and bucky is good
so i just decided to to do this little
dance and uh
and i was 100 sure that they would cut
it
uh so i'm i'm thrilled that they kept it
in the
in the final cut and to see the
reactions i mean some of my friends
texted me and and uh you know
put on their their own tunes to to the
dance i mean it's it's really funny
i wanna i wanna party with zemo oh you
should he's done a lot of very bad
things but audiences are really
starting to root for him even over john
walker did you ever expect that people
would be loving zemo
and hating captain america
it's hilarious they should all join team
zemo
and i think it's a good choice um
no but um i mean what was established in
in civil war
already and what i loved about you know
kevin feige's uh reinterpretation of
that
character was that he is not a cliche
you know one-dimensional evil guy uh
who just does that creepy stuff with no
for no reason i mean um he um does it
out of a very human
you know motivation uh he has suffered
severe loss
although i always you know disagreed
with um
zemo's radical methods uh i kind of
empathize
you know with him knowing where he was
coming from and that ambiguity
uh is carried on in the show as well so
you cannot totally dislike him no
no you're right was there anything you
were surprised to learn about zemo
this time around like i love that we're
getting a glimpse into like his rich boy
life
well a lot of cars and uh a private jet
i didn't know that before um either
uh um no there was a lot of uh
a lot of surprises when i opened these
uh scripts
um it was just a different take
uh on on this character
and and um and again it's
it's it's fun because it doesn't become
redundant it doesn't become
um boring and uh
and also to have that triangle i love
that's
i always love these you know these
scenes between these three because um
i mean they couldn't be more different
and and and
and they all come from very different
places obviously but um
what i always liked is that underneath
it all
there's a mutual understanding and
almost a respect well maybe not a
respect but
an understanding for you know uh
for the traumas that each of them had
you know
they're all haunted by the demons of
their past
they've all gone through a lot have lost
people
very dear to them and so this dynamic
between
those three uh getting to know each
other
becoming a boy band uh it was was
something that i uh
that i really enjoyed i love that
there's there's a lot of theories about
um about zemo's mask some say he might
be trying to look like thanos
will we get more backstory into why he
wears the mask
in upcoming episodes well like my
character
zemo i love being opaque and mysterious
secretive and enigmatic and uh i won't
tell you
a thing um fair enough you will have to
you'll have to check it out i i couldn't
and wouldn't
answer that question
i was wondering when you were gonna show
up
we get a cliffhanger at the end of this
recent episode wakanda's coming for zemo
what can you tease about the rest of the
season i'm the master of
of spoilers so i'm i'm uh yeah i know i
i'm really scared to death when it comes
uh to
to these questions um i would rather not
say
a word you really have to to watch it um
it still it continues being
fun what is what really uh impressed me
is that they
managed to uh keep that cinematic
level to the to the show uh it really
looks like it feels like a
long movie like a six-hour feature
with and there will be very interesting
turns and
and and and and surprises um
that i can uh assure you but uh uh i
i i'd rather not say anything well i'll
let you off the hook because i'm out of
time but
lovely talking to you again loving the
stash and loving the show
thank you so much bye everybody
you